he's a businessman inventor
philanthropist and television
personality he has an estimated net
worth of 150 million dollars
he leads close to 6000 employees in over
a hundred cities across the u.s. he is
Marcus lemonis and here are his top ten
rules for success you know there's this
myth that that people think they don't
need a business plan and oftentimes I
find business owners who have an idea of
a great one and where they miss it is
the execution they don't go through the
process of writing things down because
any time you can take pen to paper and
write out your ideas and share them with
other people and get feedback which is
essentially a business plan you're going
to do better it could be a whiteboard in
an office it could be notes taken on
your computer or in a journal but I want
it to start with something that says
here's what my product or services
here's how I'm going to attack the
market here's how I'm going to beat the
competition here's how I'm going to
learn from my competitors here's what
I'm going to take from my customers and
here's the kind of people I need to
surround myself with if you don't answer
those questions then really you're just
kind of like a like a dodgeball game
just going to go out there and wing it
and at some point you're going to get
whacked on the side of the head you know
cash flow to me is is important but
working capital from the beginning is
also important I find that people come
to me with a projection about their
business it's a brand new idea they
think they're going to make money in six
months they don't make money in six
months and they don't have a back-up
plan they don't have a reserve they
don't have a line of credit and so they
go out of business and that's probably
the single biggest reason small
businesses closed not because the idea
is terrible now because they have bad
people they don't have the sufficient
amount of working capital one of the
things that I do do before I go to bed
at night is that make a quick list of
the things that I know I have to deal
with the next day and I try to get those
knocked out before noon because from
noon on it's kind of like the wild wild
west I don't know what's going to happen
I don't know what new issues going to
come up and so you want to really be
smart about your time to knock out the
things that you have - who do I have to
talk to what do I have to review what do
I have to do with a bank or an employee
or one of the businesses you want to get
out what I would call the housekeeping
you get the housekeeping done in the
morning and then you get to kind of go
farm the fields for the rest of the day
and part of the challenge or part of the
challenge for me at least is that that
lines get very blurry of when the day
actually shuts off and that can present
a real challenge to you know your
personal life and your friends and in
kind of that balance so it's it's hard
but the first part of my day is the
focus let me tell you we need you here
and this is more important than any pie
will ever make but I'm gonna need your
help before you leave because I got to
get some stuff done and you're gonna be
our leader here okay okay but in order
for you to be able to have a good peace
of mind I wanted to give you some money
I'm gonna give you six months worth of
pay okay when you come back you will be
fully in charge of this location and I'm
gonna pay you $1,000 a week so you don't
have to bartend okay okay
I'm gonna give you a check and it should
help you just kind of just be able to
rest take care of your baby
and then when you come back you're gonna
bust somebody's ass okay
Wow thank you the reality of it is is
that the employee is number one because
if the employee is happy ultimately the
customer is going to be happy if the
employee is happy they're going to take
care of the assets of your business if
the employee is happy they will have a
pride of ownership and they'll stand
side by side with you and they'll fight
during the tough times and they'll
celebrate during the good times if you
take care of your employees they will
put the customer first but if you don't
it won't matter there won't be any
customers you don't take care of your
employees there'll be nobody to help
them you'll have no business I say
follow your passion which should be
sports I say if you have a passion for
business you also better have a
knowledge for it and so if people want
to own a business they better have
worked for somebody else for a while
and they better have an intrinsic
knowledge of that industry and so it
would be like me getting into you know
the barber business and I never went to
learn how to cut hair I shouldn't have a
knowledge if I don't have the knowledge
then I better have a partner or I better
have a manager or a leader in place
who's vested in the business who does
have a knowledge and so three guys want
to open up a restaurant because they
think it's cool to open up a restaurant
but none of them know how to cook or
suede tables they shouldn't be in that
business entrepreneurs who have authored
a product or a process that isn't
working today have to make the bold step
of reinventing themselves I talk about
it all the time how over the course of
my life whether it was at 12 years old
or 18 years old or 25 years old or even
today I'm constantly working to reinvent
myself I'm not any different than a
package on a shelf people have to feel
that it's relevant they have to see the
warning labels they have to understand
the contents it has to be appealing it
has to provide value to people and so
when an entrepreneur has a product or a
process that they've authored and
they're not willing to change it then
they're going to end up like Circuit
City or Montgomery Ward or Sears or Fiat
or whatever these brands are that don't
exist anymore right every single company
in this country today if they're not
evolving they're dying and I don't know
why an entrepreneur would think that
they would be exempt from that process
I'm not interested in their ego I'm not
interested in their pride I'm not
interested in their feelings I'm
interested in their business being
successful and so I think not only does
their business have to do it but but we
as entrepreneurs have to do it as well
let's talk about the myth that your
product is already good enough people
often develop a new product and it's
fantastic and it hits the market like in
a blaze of glory and it sells and
there's back orders if you're delivering
them a good product or service today
they're still going to expect something
better tomorrow
and the one thing you have to worry
about is there's a competitor out there
somebody they can mimic your offering
and so you always have to stay one step
ahead of them and so when products don't
morph into something new they don't
develop into something better and
smarter and faster and less expensive
it's probably the biggest takeaway less
expensive then people are going to find
alternatives for me I'd like to go out
and study the competition that's how I
reinvent myself I go out and I study
businesses aren't exactly the same but
they run their business with a set of
ethics and a set of principles that are
second to none and they can be in a
space that's completely different than
mine but I learned something from them
and I think we do that enough how many
people you meet at a party or at a
restaurant that tell you they're
entrepreneurs and in the past I used to
say no does that mean you don't work and
so an entrepreneur to me is is kind of a
nonsensical word you either a business
owner or you are a team member one of
the two and I think being a business
owner is the hardest thing to do in this
country you take your money hopefully
not your mother's money but you take
your money and you invest in an idea
which is essentially investing in
yourself but if you do it solely to make
money you're going to lose and you
really have to do it and I know that a
lot of people out there get up every
morning in the hustle right and they're
driving in the car right now and they're
the way to a job that they may not love
yeah and I would encourage them just to
stick to the grind get the Paycheck pay
the bills learn learn and learn and to
many young kids out of college tell me
they're entrepreneurs and I tell them
you can't be an entrepreneur until
you've worked for somebody else and you
know what it feels like to be fired
right to be called on the mat or to be
harassed or to be mismanaged you got to
know what that feels like so that when
you're on the other side yeah you can be
respectful to people yeah you know I
have a terrible fear that I lay awake at
night with and that's the fear of
failure
and the embarrassment that comes with it
and so people like to have a lot of
pride and say and I'm I'm not
embarrassed I'm not I think anybody
that's an entrepreneur deep down really
deep down in their soul has a fear of
failure what will people say what will
people think and it's hard it's a hard
challenge and so I try to ignore it as
much as I can but I I find it kind of
haunting me and so I push through
because I really believe that I have an
obligation to keep trying and trying and
trying and I've had plenty of failure in
my life what happened was when I turned
35 and 2008-9 happened I became much
more comfortable with admitting my
vulnerability acknowledging my mistakes
saying when I was wrong
showing my cards and saying I was stupid
crumbs could be one of those situations
where I tried to outsmart something and
now I don't think it's going to fail but
I have to be realistic it could anything
I do could fail I go through thousands
and thousands of applications and
sometimes I pick businesses that are new
and innovative and the products exciting
and sometimes I pick businesses that are
pretty ordinary when it's ordinary and
it's saturated biggest challenges you're
now dealing with the commodity and so
whether it's a coffee shop or a yogurt
shop the question is is the product
relevant in the marketplace and if it's
saturated can you rise to the top of the
list I want to encourage people not to
run away from saturated markets but I
want you to run away if you don't have
the time the resources the energy the
people the process or the attention to
detail
to be best in class and so if you're
going to open up a coffee shop in a very
crowded market you better have something
that's unique
it better be experiential your product
better be amazing your process better be
on point and the people that sell it
better be better in product knowledge
and better and experience than anything
else I guess a different way to look at
it is if you go into an industry that's
not saturated you should probably ask
yourself is there a reason that nobody
else is in this I can't be the only
person with this idea and so you get
into a business that's not saturated it
may tell you that there's not really a
market there I think I'd like to get
into the hanger business
I mean is it saturated is it not is
there a reason that everybody's not in
it I don't really mind whether it's
saturated or not I have to like the
product it has to be relatable and it
has to be not totally recession proof
but it has to be kind of recession proof
I think it's important that if you're
going to get into a business and you're
thinking about taking your last 50
thousand dollars and getting it getting
into something you better have something
that is unique if it's going to be a
commodity and you better better make
sure that you really understand what
happens when the economy goes up and
down and study those trends thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because black asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of Marcus lemonis is top
ten rules you like the mess meant the
most to you leave it in the comments
that I'm going to join in discussion
thank you guys so much for watching it
you too believe and I'll see you soon